we're asked to multiply 1.45 times 10 to
the 8th times 9.2 times 10 to the
negative 12 times 3.01 times 10 to the
negative fifth and express the product
in both decimal and scientific notation
so this is
1.45 times 10 to the 8th power
times
and i could just write the parentheses
again like this but i'm just going to
write it as another multiplication times
9.2
times 10 to the negative 12 and then
times
times 3.01
times 10 to the negative fifth all this
meant when i wrote these parentheses
times next to each other i'm just going
to multiply this expression times this
expression times this expression and
since everything is involved
multiplication it actually doesn't
matter what order i multiply in and so
with that in mind i can swap the order
here this is going to be the same thing
as 1.45
that's that right there
times 9.2
times 9.2
times
3.01
times 3.01
times 10 to the 8th let me do that in
that purple color
times ten to the eighth so times ten to
the eighth
times ten to the negative twelfth power
ten to the negative twelfth power times
ten to the negative fifth power
times 10 to the negative fifth power and
this is useful because now i have all of
my powers of 10 right over here i could
put parentheses around that and i have
all of my non-powers of 10 right over
there and so i can simplify it if i have
i have the same base 10 or right over
here so i can add the exponents this is
going to be 10
to the
8
minus 12
minus 5 power
minus 5 power and then all of this on
the left hand side let me get a
calculator out
i have
1.45 you could do it by hand but this is
a little bit faster and less likely to
make a careless mistake times nine point
two
times
three point zero one which is equal to
forty point one five three four
so this is equal to forty
point one five 3 4 and of course this is
going to be multiplied times 10 to this
thing and so if you simplify this
exponent you get 40.1534
times 10 to the 8 minus 12 is negative 4
minus 5 is negative 9. 10 to the
negative 9 power now you might be
tempted to say that this is already in
scientific notation because it has some
number here times some power of 10 but
this is not quite official scientific
notation and that's because in order for
it to be in scientific notation this
number right over here has to be greater
than or equal to 1 and less than 10 and
this is obviously not less than 10
essentially for it to be in scientific
notation you want a non-zero digit right
over here and then you want your decimal
and then the rest of everything else so
here and you want a non-zero
single digit over here here we obviously
have here we have two digits this is
larger than 10 or this is greater than
or equal to 10. you want this thing to
be less than 10 and greater than or
equal to 1. so the best way to do that
is to write this thing right over here
in scientific notation this is the same
thing as 4.01534
times 10. and one way to think about it
is to go from 40 to 4 we had to move
this decimal over to the left moving a
decimal over to the left to go from 40
to 4 you're dividing by 10. so you have
to multiply by 10 so it all equals out
divide by 10 and then multiply by 10 or
another way to write it or another way
to think about is 4.0 and all this stuff
times 10 is going to be 40 times
0.1534 and so you're going to have 4 all
of this times 10 to the first power
that's the same thing as 10
times
this thing times 10 to the negative
ninth power and then once again powers
of 10 so 10 to the first times 10 to the
negative 9 is going to be 10 to the
negative 8th power
10 to the negative 8th power and we
still have this
point zero one five three four times ten
to the negative eight and now we have
written it in scientific
now we have written it in scientific
notation now they wanted us to express
it in both decimal and a scientific
notation and when they're asking us to
write it in decimal notation they
essentially want us to multiply this out
expand this out and so the way to think
about it
write these digits out so i have 4
0 1 5
3 4.
and if i'm just looking at this number i
start with the decimal right over here
now every time every time i divide by 10
or if i multiply by 10 to the negative 1
i'm moving this over to the left one
spot so 10 to the negative 1 if i
multiply by 10 to the negative 1 that's
the same thing as dividing by 10 and so
i'm moving the decimal over to the left
one
here i'm multiplying by 10 to the
negative 8. or you could say i'm
dividing by 10 to the 8th power so i'm
going to want to move the decimal to the
left 8 times so move
move
decimal
to left
8
8 times and one way to remember it look
this is a very very very very small
number if i multiply this i should get a
smaller number so i should be moving the
decimal to the left if this was a
positive 8 then this would be a very
large number and so if i multiply by a
large power of 10 i'm going to be moving
the decimal to the right so this is
going to be this whole thing should be
evaluate it should evaluate to being
smaller than 4.015
so i move the decimal eight times to the
left eight times to the left
i move it one time to the left to get it
right over here and then the next seven
times i'm just going to add zeros so one
two three four five
six seven zeros and i'll put a zero in
front of the decimal just to clarify it
so now i notice if you include this
digit right over here i have a total of
eight digits i have an eight i have i
have eight sorry i have seven zeros and
this digit gives us eight so again one
two three four five six seven eight the
best way to think about it is i started
with the decimal right here i moved once
twice three
4 5 6 7 8 times that's what multiplying
times 10 to the negative 8 did for us
and i get this number right over here
and when you see a number like this you
start to appreciate why we write things
in scientific notation
this is much easier to
it takes less space to write and you
immediately know roughly how big this
number is this is much harder to write
you might even forget a zero when you
write it or you might add a zero and now
the person has to sit and count the
zeros to figure out essentially how
large or get a rough sense of how large
this this this thing is it's one two
three four five six seven zeros and you
have this digit right here that's what
gets us to that eight but this is a much
much more
complicated looking number than the one
in scientific notation